good
afternoon I'm Matthew spaling associate
vice president dean of educational
programs for Hillsdale College in
Washington DC welcome to the Alan P
Kirby Center for constitutional studies
and citizenship a hillso college is an
independent institution of Higher
Learning founded in
1844 grateful for civil and religious
liberty and believing that the diffusion
of learning is essential to the prity of
those
blessings and so for 170 years Hillsdale
has provided moral instruction education
in the liberal arts to students
regardless of race Creed or color the
Kirby Center in Washington DC is to
extend the college's mission to the
nation's capital by teaching students
staffers citizens and Statesmen about
the first principles of Liberty and
constitutional government and how to
apply those principles in today's
difficult
politics today's lecture is co-sponsored
by the YG Network an independent
nonprofit dedicated to supporting
conservative policies and the efforts of
policy makers who who fight for those
policies uh they believe that by seeking
reforms that create jobs encourage
Innovation instill fiscal discipline and
reform Key
Programs uh we can create an environment
for America's business businesses and
entrepreneurs to succeed and flourish
they have recent released Room to Grow
conservative forms for a limited
government and a thriving middle class
copies of which were on your chairs
today the idea of conservative policy
reform and the application of principle
today's challenges come together in our
speaker
I first uh met Marco Rubio before he
became speaker of the Florida House of
Representatives we were trying to
remember when exactly that was uh when
he invited me to a Miami to lead a first
principal's Retreat for him and his
incoming legislative leadership what was
immediately clear is that here was a man
who knew what he was doing because he
knew what he
believed that has much to do with his
background born to workingclass parents
who had fled Fidel cord's Cuba he went
to school in Miami graduated from the
University of of Florida and the
University of Miami law school he is
happily married and he and his wife
Janette have four children from 202 to
2008 he served in the Florida House of
Representatives during which he was
majority whip majority leader and
speaker since January 2011 he has served
as United States senator from Florida
during this time in the Senate he has
become a leading reform thinker aiming
to conserve the principles of Liberty
while at the same time addressing the
real and practical challenges we face as
a people today he is speaking on finding
Economic Security in an insecure time on
behalf of hillvale college and the YG
Network please join me in welcoming
Senator Marco
Rubio thank you thank
you thank you very much thank you to the
YG network and to Hillsdale College for
hosting this and for this opportunity
that we have today I want to thank all
of you for being a part of it and I'm
grateful for this opportunity to talk to
you about something something that's
very near and dear to my heart so I'll
begin by talking about both of my
parents who were born into difficult
circumstances my father lost his mother
when he was a young boy and he had to
quit school and so he could go to work
my mother was raised by a father who was
disabled who struggled to provide for
his Seven Daughters when both of my
parents were young they had dreams for
their future my father wanted to be a
successful businessman my mother wanted
to be a famous movie
star but uh but like most people whoever
lived they were born into societies
where the dreams of people like them
really didn't stand a chance in fact
they felt trapped in the circumstances
and they were so frustrated by their
inability to improve their lives and so
they came here to the one place on Earth
where how you start out in life does not
determine where you end up they came to
the United States of
America now here they never became
wealthy either they work service jobs at
hourly wages we never had a maid at our
house my my mother was one for a living
and they didn't have fancy cars my
father drove the same embarrassing 73
Shelly Chevy andala for over 20
years and yet I consider myself to be
from a background of great
privilege because I was privileged to be
raised in a stable family privileged
that my parents had jobs that allowed
them to provide for their
children and I was privileged to be born
in a Land of equal
opportunity the one place on Earth where
the son of a bartender and a maid could
achieve the same things as a son of a
president or a
millionaire I come from privilege
because while the hope of a better life
is a universal one it is also one few
people ever get the chance to
achieve we are blessed to live in a
country however on Whose Cornerstone is
etched the principle that all people
have a god-given right to go as far as
their talent and their effort will take
them in fact here because so many people
here have been able to achieve the
universal dream of a better
life this dream has actually come to
Bear our name they call it the American
dream now for most this dream has never
been about becoming rich or famous it's
about things like having a good job that
pays enough to own a home feed your
family and save for retirement about the
flexibility to work and spend time with
your family the freedom to worship as
you please and live without fear for
your family's safety and ultimately it's
a about giving your children the
opportunity at a life even better than
your
own the American dream holds us together
as one people it defines us as a special
Nation we can overcome bad presidents
and tough economies and even divisive
issues but if we were to ever lose the
American
dream we would lose our
identity there simply cannot be an
America without the American
dream and that is is why the crisis
before us today is that there are
millions of our people who feel that
this dream is slipping away now the
American dream is still attainable but
it has gotten increasingly difficult to
achieve for far too
many wages have stagnated everyday costs
have risen industries that once
flourished have dried up their jobs
shipped overseas or lost to Automation
and millions go to sleep each night
overcome with the sense that they are
just one bad
breakway from complete Financial ruin
over the last six years this insecurity
has coiled itself around people from
every Walk of Life but it's been
particularly difficult for three sets of
Americans first for our more than 10
million single
mothers many of them have been abandoned
by the by the father of their children
left to face the struggles of Parenthood
all by themselves many of them were
stuck in jobs with low wages and
inflexible work hours and at every turn
they feel like the deck is stacked
against them their everyday costs rise
while their paychecks remain
stagnant they lose jobs because after
school care closes in the early evening
and they can't work late they feel
guilty that they can't afford and they
don't have the time to sign their
children up for soccer or dance like the
other kids do and they feel helpless to
get their children out of failing
schools we also see the erosion of the
American dream in the lives of many
Young Americans including many recent
college
graduates their generation is coming of
age in an era of Lowered
Expectations where too often their caps
and gowns come not just with hope and
excitement but also with Dread and
apprehension many of them did everything
they were told was necessary to
succeed but now they sit in their
childhood bedrooms under the weight of
thousands in student loans unable to
start a career or a
family and finally we see the rising
struggles of our workingclass families
parents who are work longer and harder
than ever before and yet are far are
falling further and further behind the
workers who search in vain for good jobs
that once supported their families and
small business owners on the verge of
losing what they fought their entire
lives to
create for millions of single parents
and Young Americans and Working Families
the promise that hard work and
perseverance would lead to a better life
This Promise has gone
unfulfilled and as a result too many are
starting to believe the American dream
is no longer possible for people like
them the erosion of this dream is not
simply the result of a Great Recession
in fact it is primarily the result of a
rapid and disruptive transformation of
our economy a transformation being
driven by Automation and
globalization you see there was once a
time when we were one of the few
developed economies in the
world but now there are dozens of
developed economies that have lowered
taxes and cut regulations in an effort
to attract job creating investment away
from us there was once a time when
people like my parents with limited
formal education could still find jobs
that paid enough to make it to the
middle class but now because of advances
in technology virtually all the good
jobs require a level of Education well
beyond high
school but instead of adjusting to the
realities of this new era many of our
institutions are failing
us and none more so than our federal
government instead of attracting jobs to
our Shores through simplifying taxes and
regulations our federal government is
imposing higher taxes and more
regulations that push investment and
Innovation to other countries instead of
anti-poverty programs that promote work
and education so our people can emerge
from poverty we are pumping more money
into programs that have failed us now
for over half a
century instead of taking steps to make
higher education more available and more
affordable we pour resources into a
system that is expensive
inaccessible and quite frankly is
graduating way too many people with
unemployable
degrees and instead of modernizing our
retirement programs to make them
accessible to
everyone we put more money into
unsustainable programs that were
designed in the
1930s and the result is that a growing
number of people feel completely
alienated from our government and from
our
leaders they feel that no one here in
Washington understands what they're
facing and no one here has answers to
their
challenges so by the way it should be no
surprise that disapproval of our
government and pessimism about the
direction of our country have reached an
all-time high because the inability of
our leaders to respond to the challenges
and the opportunities of the 21st
century is denying a growing number of
people access to the American
dream now President Obama deserves
credit for hosting a summit earlier this
week focused on helping Working
Families but the truth is the ideas he
offered are symbolic more than they are
substantive they don't go far enough in
fact up to this point in his presidency
his plan to restore the American dream
has been an old and familiar one raise
taxes create more regulations pour more
money into government programs and
accuse anyone who doesn't agree with him
of not
caring well the globalization and
technological advances that are changing
our economy they are producing disrupt
of
challenges but they also present
exciting
opportunities the opportunity to
innovate faster and in more areas than
ever before the opportunity to sell the
products we make and the services we
provide to more people in more places
than ever
before this new century can also be an
American Century with the American Dream
Within Reach of more people than ever
before but our current path the path of
the old and tired ideas of big
government this path will never lead us
to that better
future to restore the American dream we
need a policy agenda designed
specifically for the 21st
century a limited government and free
enterprise movement that applies the
principles of our founding to the
challenges and the opportunities facing
Americans in their daily
lives Americans like Christine a young
single mother of two preschool age girls
Christine lives in Florida and she's the
primary provider for her two daughters
Christine works at a pet boarding
facility she makes $370 a week after
taxes daycare for the girls cost $235 a
week which she says is like signing over
a paycheck every month Christine knows
that the key to a better job is
acquiring new skills so she started
taking online courses and early
childhood education she hoped that this
would lead to a higher salary but also a
more flexible work schedule so she could
spend more time with her
daughters but like millions of other
Americans our outdated higher education
system left Christine unable to
finish because the online courses she'd
been taking cost her around $1,200 per
course and even if she had received a
scholarship or a pel grant she still
felt like the time and resources
required were simply too much given her
responsibilities at work and at
home so Christine dropped out
she dedicated herself to earning more
money any way she could she sells
nutrition supplements at a local farmers
market on weekends she makes costume
accessory for girls birthday parties and
sells them online and she got rid of
everything that wasn't essential cable
even her cell phone she was determined
to live
independently but nothing she tried was
enough no matter how hard she worked her
earnings were simply too little and her
costs too
great and so today Christine along with
42 million other women in
America finds herself on the edge of
poverty and slipping
over the solutions President Obama and
his party offer single mothers like her
have not
worked their idea of helping is to spend
more money on programs that do nothing
to help Christine Escape poverty their
idea of helping her get an education is
a gimmic designed to win elections
rather than reforms designed to bring
higher education within her reach
and the result is that Americans like
Christine are feeling pessimistic about
the future of our country and they are
frustrated that no one in Washington
seems to understand the challenges
facing
them here's worst of
all they hold little hope that their
lives will
improve to restore the American dream we
have to change that first we need modern
reforms to our anti-poverty programs
reforms that would incentivize and
reward the work Christine does now while
also helping her acquire the skills she
needs for a better job
later these Innovations will never come
from the federal government's rigid one-
siiz fits-all
approach that's why I've proposed
combining all of our existing Federal
anti-poverty money into a flex fund that
would be made available to the states
which do have the ability to design
Innovative and targeted programs to
address the unique needs of their
residents liberals offer up increases in
taxes in the minim minimum wage as ways
of helping the struggling earn
more what they don't tell you is that
these policies would result in many
people like Christine potentially losing
their jobs so as an alternative I've
proposed replacing the flawed existing
earn income tax credit with a wage
enhancement credit that would boost her
wage at the pet
kennel we also need to bring education
within Christine's reach the big
government solution for the cost of
higher education is to slightly lower
the monthly payment on existing students
student loans but instead of short-term
gimmicks like this a better approach
would be to implement the reforms I
outlined earlier this year that would
both lower costs and encourage the
creation of more affordable and
accessible routes to higher education
and to a
degree the online courses that Christine
was taking by the way are actually more
expensive than the cost of physically
attending her local Community College
even if she receiv received financial
help she couldn't find an option that
allowed her enough flexibility to work
full-time and raise her family and the
reason for all of this is an outdated
process called
accreditation a school must be
accredited to award degrees that provide
financial aid but here's the catch
established institutions control the
accrediting
process and as a result the entrenched
higher education cartel has the power to
block out Innovative lower cost
competitors so I have proposed that
Congress established a new indep
dependent accrediting process designed
to open the door for more Innovative and
affordable schools and I propose ways to
help Christine package the free tools
all around her into an employable degree
tools such as online resources
apprenticeships mentorships and personal
study now unlike most traditional
students Christine also needs affordable
daycare for her daughters even with
government help her out- of pocket costs
run into hundreds a month and if she
decided to pursue her education full
time she would lose her current Child
Care Credit so I propose allowing
parents who are pursuing their education
full-time to remain eligible for the
Child Care
Credit daycare is by far the is is by is
far from the only burdensome expense
that Christine has by the way from rent
to her electric bill to car insurance
gas and food the cost of living is
rising around her like flood
waters that's why Senator Mike Lee and I
have been working together to design
pro- family tax reforms as part of our
upcoming proposal the per child tax
credit she currently receives would be
raised from $1,000 to
$2500 so she can keep more of her own
money and that credit would be made
refundable up to the total payroll and
income tax liabilities which means
whatever isn't saved through the through
her reduction of tax liability would be
received in the form of a check and
finally given the dreams she has for her
children Christine is worried about the
fact that her daughters will soon be
forced to attend public schools that do
not meet her standards for their
education too many poor parents are
denied the opportunity to send their
children to the school of their choice
they can't afford to move to a
neighborhood with better schools and
they can't afford private school
tuition and that's why I've proposed a
federal tax credit that encourages
contributions to scholarship granting
organizations that distribute private
school scholarships to needing children
like
hers we cannot Preserve erve our
standing as an exceptional Nation if the
American dream isn't possible for people
like
Christine and if we don't put in place
modern conservative reforms that will
help her earn more to keep more of what
she earns to go back to school and to
send her girls to the best school
possible then Christine and millions of
Americans like her are going to be left
behind but the single most important
thing we can do to help her and every
American is to unleash the prosperity
that comes from a growing free
enterprise economy
and no group of Americans would benefit
from robust economic growth more than
Young Americans like Jennifer and Evan
Jennifer and Evan both live in my
hometown of Miami they've never met one
another but they share a similar and
increasingly common
story Jennifer graduated four years ago
from Florida International University
with a degree in public administration
she was the first in her family to go to
college growing up her father told her
what mine told me that an education was
her ticket to a life better than his own
but four years after earning her degree
she and her father fell on tough times
her father was laid off and the only job
Jennifer can find was unrelated to her
degree it barely paid enough to get by
much less help out her father the way
she wish she could so they both had to
move in with Jennifer's
grandmother meanwhile Evan graduated
last year from Liberty University with a
degree in sports management but also
with a mountain of student loan debt he
moved back to Florida to begin the
full-time job of looking for a full-time
job and he's still looking
today he was recently able to find two
part-time jobs one is at a retail store
the other allows him a glimpse of the
industry he hopes of breaking into he
helps out as a game day assistant for
the Miami
Heat between his two jobs Evan brings
home about $500 a month this was barely
enough to scrape by to begin
with but recently he received a letter
starting next week on the 1st of July he
will have to start paying his nearly
$20,000 in student loan debt his
finances were already teetering on the
brink and this will likely push them
over the good news is that neither
Jennifer nor Evan has lost
hope but far too many Young Americans
like them are starting to accept their
current struggles as a new
normal they worry that A J that a
growing job producing economy is a thing
of the past in fact just this morning we
received more evidence that our economy
is headed in the wrong direction during
the first three months of this year not
only did our economy not grow it shrank
by 2.9% the biggest drop in five
years it doesn't have to be this way if
we can put in place policies that will
spur Dynamic economic growth and make
higher education more affordable we can
restore the American dream for millions
of Young
Americans in order to achieve that
economic growth growth that leads to
millions of better paying jobs what we
need are policies that incentivize
investment and
Innovation which is why I've proposed
tax reforms that make America a more
attractive place to invest and
Regulatory reforms that help this Remain
the best place in the world to
innovate this will create millions of
jobs for our graduates but creating jobs
alone is not going to be enough Young
Americans still need to be able to
acquire skills without also acquiring in
a lifetime of student loan debt for
example Jennifer knows that getting a
master's degree will help her get the
kind of job that she desires but she
doesn't want to go $50,000 into debt to
get
it as I mentioned before the first step
to making College more affordable is
allowing more Innovation and competition
and higher education so you don't have
to borrow that much to begin with but we
also need to think of easier ways to pay
for and to plan for the cost of a degree
for Evan his loans are the the primary
obstacle that are preventing him from
pursuing his dreams now going into col
in college he knew the cost but what he
didn't know was how hard it would be to
find a job with his
degree which is why I have filed
bipartisan legislation with Senator Ron
widen that would require schools to tell
students how much their graduates earn
with their chosen
degree second I I've proposed making
income paced repayment the automatic
repayment method for student loans
this way evans's loan payments would be
directly correlated to how much he earns
each month removing the risk of default
and third I have proposed an alternative
to student loans called student
investment plans students would be able
to enter into an agreement with a
private firm in which the firm pays for
the students education in for in return
for a percentage of their salary for a
set number of years after
graduation modern reforms that lead to
economic growth and increased education
options would benefit all of Americans
they would benefit single mothers like
Christine and young people like Jennifer
and Evan but they would also help
Working Families like the broal Danny
and Becky broal operate a small business
called Foreign Accents which sells Home
Furnishings from all over the world they
are the only two employees not including
summer and weekend help from their three
sons aged 13 16 19 the Bro started their
business 17 years ago and it's always
been small but it's always provided
enough to get by
that is until the recession hit in
2007 the impact on their business was
nearly
devastating to survive they began
racking up expenses on multiple credit
cards and they knew it was a desperate
move but they had no choice and sure
enough it
backfired a few light payments after a
few light payments the banks started
hiking their interest rates and the debt
on their shoulders began to
compound at this point like at every
time of trial in their lives Daniel and
Becky leaned on their faith to to get
through with three boys who depended on
them they prayed that God would reveal
the Right Way
Forward together they discussed their
options one of them could go back to
school and try to get another job but
the job market made this a risky gamble
when weighed against the costs of an
education as Daniel said he never felt
that was the right
answer and then just when the situation
seemed to hit rock bottom a couple of
contract started trickling in a few
customers returned to the shop business
wasn't what it was before but it was
enough to break even and stop the debt
from rising they decided to dig in and
try to see the business
through but just as things are starting
to look up they were hit with another
problem and this one came directly from
Washington
DC it's called
Obamacare and Daniel described what
happened to his premiums around the time
the recession hit his family paid $440 a
month for health insurance but year
after year as the Obamacare debate raged
on and eventually the law was signed the
the premium started edging up this was a
burden but it was nothing compared to
what came when the law went into effect
his monthly premium shot up from
$520 to
$660 and worse his deductible doubled
from $2500 to
$5,000 so they couldn't afford it so
they dropped their coverage they turned
to a faith-based program called meta
share which allows members to spread out
the burden of costs and
coverage now the good news is today the
bro are getting by their eldest son
helps out with a business while working
toward his online education the youngest
two look forward to one day getting
their degrees as well despite their
struggles they find fulfillment and
purpose in the business they've worked
the better part of 20 years to
build but they're uncertain about the
future they don't have much money put
away for retirement in fact Daniel joked
said he was thinking about running for
congress because he heard our benefits
were
great our outdated laws taxes and
education system and the growing burden
of Obamacare are making life harder than
it needs to be for Working Families like
the broal and in order to restore the
American dream we need to change that my
growth agenda will help them by
elevating the entire economy as they
have found throughout 17 years in
business when the economy is growing and
thriving more customers come by their
shop progrowth tax reform will allow
them to fully expense every investment
they make in their company making it
easier for them to expand earn more and
maybe even create a job or two pro-
family tax reform will help them with
the cost of living for their two younger
Sons the boals receive a child tax
credit of
$1,000 but just like Christine the
reforms I'm working on with Mike Lee
would raise this to as much as
$2500 and it would make it
refundable pro-education tax reform
would help them with the cost of higher
education for their kids joined by
representative Congressman Aaron Shock I
have proposed that we update and
consolidate higher education tax
incentives into one simple easy to
understand tax credit that applies
universally to higher education and
skills obain obtainment and Market
centered Health Care reform will help
them grow their businesses and receive
quality Care at an affordable
price Obamacare is a disaster but the
answer is not to Simply return to the
way things were before the answer is to
repeal and replace Obamacare with modern
market- centered reforms reforms that
would give the broal control over their
health care Decisions by giving them the
power to buy the kind of health
insurance they want from any company
they choose at a price they can
afford and finally we need to bring the
prospect of a dignified and Secure
Retirement within their reach retirement
in the 21st century will look different
than it has in the past people will work
longer not only because they have to but
also because like the broyal they enjoy
it but the three pillars of our current
American Retirement System
Social Security pensions and personal
savings are
crumbling and the answer is to implement
modern solutions that save Social
Security and Medicare without making any
changes for people currently in the
system solutions that gradually raise
the retirement age for workers like
myself but we must make it
easier and more profitable for those who
choose to work Beyond retirement age by
removing the retirement earnings test
and eliminating the payroll tax on older
workers as well
we must make it saving easier for the 75
million Americans who don't have 401ks
through their employers last month I
proposed opening the federal
government's Thrift Savings Plan which
is like a 401k only with lower costs and
generally better returns opening it up
to all Americans who lack access to an
employer
plan so Daniel and Becky can have
congress's retirement plan after all no
Congressional Campaign
necessary let me conclude by just saying
a few things about this you know growing
up I knew this country was special from
my earliest days my parents taught me
that no dream was too big and there was
no goal that was Out Of Reach for
me because I was an American
son each person I've introduced you to
today also believes that America
special but they're starting to wonder
if it's still true for people like them
and they increasingly doubt it will be
true for their own
children their American Dreams aren't
much different than my parents Christine
wants to raise her daughters to be
strong and
self-sufficient Jennifer wants to find a
fulfilling
job Evan wants to pay off his loans and
reach Financial Security by the time
he's ready to start a family and the
broils they just want to run their
business send their children to college
and retire
securely ultimately what each of them
wants is what everyone
wants the chance to build a better life
for themselves and the chance at an even
better life for their
children this is is the dream that
defines our nation this is the dream
that binds us together as one people and
this is the dream that we are now called
upon to
restore today people like Christine and
Jennifer and Evan and the boals family
have serious doubts about whether our
current leaders are up to that task they
feel as if neither party understands
cares or has answers for the problems
that they
face for those of us who serve or aspire
to serve in public office our goal must
be to offer real hope for our future and
real change for our nation the hope of
ushering in the most prosperous and
promising era in our history and the
change that it will require to achieve
it we Americans have good reason to be
hopeful for no nation is better
positioned to access the full promise of
the 21st century
economy this new economy is all about
Innovation creativity and productivity
and we are the most creative Innovative
and prod productive people on the
planet and the changes we must make to
achieve this better future come from
fundamental truths about our nation that
government exists to empower its people
and that our free enterprise economy is
the greatest generator of opportunity
and prosperity in human
history from these principles we see
that if we reform our taxes and
regulations we can create millions of
higher paying jobs by winning the global
competition for talent investment and
Innovation and if we modernize our
outdated safety net programs and
revolutionize how we acquire and pay for
Education millions of people will have
the skills they need for the higher
paying jobs of the new
economy 21st century America was
special but 21st century America has the
potential to be even
better but this better tomorrow will not
happen on its own for two centuries this
nation has endured as an exceptional one
because each generation before us has
risen to meet the challenge Alles and
seize the opportunities of their
time now it is our turn we will either
adapt to the new era and bring about
another American
Century or like so many nations before
us our inability to address new
realities will usher in our
Decline and our success will not be
measured simply by the size of our
economy or the performance of our
stocks rather it will depend on whether
Americans like Christine and Jennifer
and Evan and the broal family will get
the real chance to earn for themselves a
better life on whether the American
dream becomes possible for them the way
it's been for so many
before this is the standard by which we
will be judged and it should be for
being the land of equal opportunity is
what sets us apart from the N from all
the nations on Earth the great cause of
our time is to reclaim the American
dream for more of our people than ever
before and in so doing to leave for our
children what our parents left for
us the single greatest nation the world
has ever known thank you for the
opportunity to talk about
that uh we have time for some questions
for the senator if you would raise your
hand and also we have microphones so it
can be picked up on our audio audio feed
yes
sir uh Senator Rubio uh thank you very
much for speaking to us today um this
morning on
MSNBC uh you voiced your opposition to
the export import Bank uh if Harry Reed
attached a measure to reauthorize XM to
A continuing resolution to fund the
government would you vote for or against
it well he shouldn't I mean that's
actually trying to force the hand of the
people of our country on an issue of
that magnitude look I I don't think we
um should shut down the federal
government um and I would hope that he
wouldn't attach such an important thing
such as continuing the operations of
cenal services to an issue which there's
legitimate debate on um but I do think
this issue is important enough to have a
full debate on not enough to shut the
government down over but certainly one
that I won't support standing on its
own
Rio thank
you we are learning um
the hard lesson that elections have
consequences if we're fortunate enough
to retain the house in the
fall and recapture the
Senate what do you think can be done
immediately to derail the freight train
that's overrunning
us well I outlined a lot of it right now
uh and and I hope that that's what we'll
do look what our country is in desperate
need of is a modern agenda that responds
to what people are going through in
their daily lives and to me it involves
three fundamental pillars the first is
we once again have to have vigorous and
robust economic growth and economic
growth in the 21st century requires us
becoming once again the best place in
the world to invest and innovate that's
why having progrowth tax reform having
uh control on our regulations that crowd
out Innovation and quite frankly dealing
with our national debt issues which
scare long-term investment these things
are critical to getting that sort of
growth the second pillar is we've got to
capacitate our people with the skills
they need for the better jobs of the
21st century and that involves both
reexamining the way we help people in
need of better jobs through our safety
net programs and creating or
incentivizing the creation of safety net
programs that don't just deal treat the
symptoms of poverty but deal with its
causes what's driving them but we also
need a higher education system that is
flexible and accessible and to me that
ranges from graduating people from high
school ready to go to work certified in
a vocation such being a plumber uh a uh
a welder uh being MW technician and
airplane mechanic all the way to making
the existing four-year college track
more affordable through the options that
I've outlined and it also includes
creating options especially for
non-traditional students who have to
work full-time and raise a family
because they're the ones that are
trapped in $9 or $10 an hour jobs and
the only way they're ever going to
Triple their pay is by acquiring the
skills they need for the jobs that pay
more I think the third element that we
don't discuss nearly enough is the role
of values in our country I believe that
you can have all the diplomas on the law
the wall you want if you don't have
certain values such as hard work and
discipline and self-control you're not
going to succeed you can't have a strong
country without strong people you can't
have strong people without strong values
no one is born with these values these
values are taught to us and they're
reinforced by the community around us
and in our families and so it should be
no surprise that the erosion of American
family life has led to an erosion in
values and a subsequent erosion in our
economy so primarily the role of having
strong families is a cumbent on us as
fathers and mothers and parents and
people living in the community but
certainly government should not be
making family life more difficult which
is why I believe in pro- family tax
reforms why I believe that we should
stop stigmatizing those groups in our
society that instill and reinforce those
positive values that we have why we
shouldn't have any government programs
that punish marriage like many of our
safety net programs do I think three
these three things are fundamental to
not just restoring the American dream
but actually making the 21st century
better than the 20th as hard as that may
be to imagine it's truly there for the
taking if we do a few things uh to get
us there I think much of this agenda are
the kinds of things that we can work on
in a bipartisan basis and some are going
to be the consequences of what I hope
will be an election that elects new
people with better
ideas um I know there have been a number
of studies showing the longer lasting
negative impacts of graduating in a
recession but it seems like American
students in general have done better
than European students so I was
wondering what you would say contributes
to um higher American college graduate
employment and if you could go into a
little more detail on the kinds of
reforms part of it is that our econom
yeah I'm sorry our our economy is now
built in a way and this is only going to
be accelerated that all the better
paying jobs of the 21st century are
going to have higher skill attainment so
when you look at halves and have knots
in America today that divide is largely
between those that have some form of
higher education and those do that do
not have some form of higher education
so it's not a surprise that that in an
that in an economy which has felt the
impact of uh technology and
globalization faster than any other on
the planet that that would be the the
fact that if you have some level of
higher education you're going to be
better off than those that do not but
even among those that have higher
education we have challenges because we
know for a fundamental fact that there
are certain degrees that are better off
of positioning you for employment than
others and I'm not sure our students
have enough information about that
before they go into their chosen degrees
likewise I think we have many students
that would greatly benefit or potential
students that would greatly benefit from
higher education I use the example of a
home health aid if you're a home health
aid you make $9 or $10 an hour and and
that's not going to go up dramatically
because that's a business that's based
on uh limited reimbursement rates the
only way you're ever going to make more
money is if you can become an ultrasound
technician or better than that a nurse
but if you have three kids at home that
you have to raise and a job you have to
go full-time you can't just drop
everything and go to school at least not
a Traditional School we've got to figure
out a way to get people living in those
circumstances access to higher education
in a way that's both cost effective and
also time effective and for me that
involves allowing people to package
learning no matter where they acquire it
from you should be able to package all
of your learning that you've acquired
through life experience work experience
internships free online courses courses
at a local community college subjects
that you've Mastered on your own and are
willing to test proficiency you should
be able to package all of that into the
equivalent of a degree that that is
recognized by the private sector that
will allow you to be employed and and
that's the dynamic that that is most in
need so there are issues with the cost
of higher education on the traditional
route but we also need to establish a
stronger
nontraditional four four nontraditional
four-year College route for millions of
people like Christine who need higher
education to get ahead but simply can't
afford it and don't have the time for
the for the traditional
model Senator uh your ideas are at least
from our perspective good ideas what do
you find in speaking to your colleagues
in the Senate and in Congress uh and
also to the American people do you find
an understanding of the connection
between the policies that have been
pursued in government and the Damage
they do to economic growth because
arguably without greater economic growth
these other problems right harder to
solve I think we still have an intelle
ideological debate about what generates
economic growth I mean primarily the
those on the left believe that economic
growth is driven by government
expenditure that government spends money
that money creates demand and that
demand drives growth I think the latest
economic reports indicate that that's
not the case you know we had an forget
about economic growth we have an economy
that's shrinking I mean we're lucky if
we break even these days and and that's
a real challenge because without growth
you can't create more jobs you can't
create more Prosperity going back to
this example that I used of the broyal
the broyal anecdotally will tell you the
better the economy is doing the more
customers we have and so this impacts
everyone so I think we still have this
debate going on about what drives growth
I think we have 200 and some odd years
of American History to prove what drives
grow growth and that is investment and
Innovation you create growth when
someone has access to money whether they
borrowed it saved it whatever it may be
and risks that money to start a new
business or grow an existing one and you
create explosive growth when you
innovate when you offer a service or a
product that no one else does and we
have seen the impact of both I mean in
your very Pockets right now I am sure is
an example of American Ingenuity and
Innovation just think about the millions
of jobs that have been created because
of the explosion and Tech Information
Technology uh you have more information
on a cell phone in your hand than you
that the information on that phone would
take a whole room this size just 15 or
20 years ago uh to to store those are
American innovations that have created
millions of jobs and opportunities we
need to remain the best place in the
world for that to happen and I have one
criticism of my party is that too often
Republicans have allowed themselves to
be a party that is not for growth but
for Big Business from time to time and
the result and and I will just tell you
that big business in many occasions is
not necessarily opposed to regulation
because regulation crowds out
competitors in Miami Florida right now
we can't get Uber to operate and I know
that's a very dcentric debate to have I
suppose because everyone in this room
has used it but it's a big deal in Miami
there's this car service it's Innovative
it challenges an established incumbent
and it can't break into the market
Market because the established incumbent
has used the power that they have over
government and the influence they have
over government to have regulations
written to keep them out that's just in
car service you find an example of that
in virtually every space in our economy
imagine if Blockbuster Video had
convinced a federal government to pass a
law to protect children from getting
their hands on bad movies they would
pass a law that says from now on if you
rent a movie you must rent it from a
retail store and you must show ID we
would never have had downloading we
would never have had Netflix or anybody
else and and think about that for a
moment but that's not outside the
stretch of the imagination those sorts
of regulations that are used to protect
incumbent Industries at the expense of
competitors happens all the time I don't
think that gets nearly enough attention
from the Republican side of the aisle
from the Democratic side of the aisle
their beliefs that more government
spending if that were the case we should
be leading the world in economic
growth um Senator I'm a rising senior in
high school and ever since I can
remember I've always wanted to one day R
run for political office what steps do
you recommend I take run run away from
it
no you know I think that's a great
question and you should actually be
congratulated for aspiring to serve our
country in public office the three
points I would make is I obviously need
to finish your education and and and get
us Broad in education as possible but
also practical uh because you're need to
go out in in the world and be able to
provide for yourself I would all second
I would say is don't run for office
until you know why you're running and it
can't be because I want to be in office
it has to be because you have a vision
for what you want the future to look
like and you think you actually have
ideas that will help get us there and
that would be my advice I've met a lot
of people that have run for office
because someone showed them a poll that
said they would win uh but then they're
very unhappy in that office unless you
just want to be called Senator but but I
think the more rewarding way to run for
office is to say I have a clear and
compelling Vision that I feel passionate
about what tomorrow should look like
like and I have ideas to get us there
that I don't hear anyone else talking
about and I want to be in a position to
make that happen and and when that
moment comes in your life that you feel
that way and it makes sense for you and
every other aspect of your life I
encourage you to pursue it public
service is a noble way to serve this
country we need more good people in
office who got if you have the mic it's
you
yeah please do something about the
children in Southwest part of the
country close the borders we cannot have
people continue to flood in here like
they
are undocumented uncared for it secure
the borders and then we have but we have
got to figure out what to do with those
children yeah that's a very complicated
situation because of who we're dealing
with we are dealing with many not all
our children but we're dealing with many
young children who have been sent here
and and that's a that problem has
multifaceted reasons for it one is that
those Central americ American countries
are extremely dangerous with an enormous
amount of drug violence and gang
violence and poverty that's the initial
driver the reason why that's the reason
why they decide to leave think about how
desperate you have to be as a parent to
put your kid on a train by themselves at
60 years of age and send him abroad
that's the reason why they decide to
leave the reason why they decide to come
here unfortunately is because somehow an
urban myth has been created in many of
these communities that if you come to
America as a child or a mother with
children you're going to get to stay and
uh and that's something that we need to
reverse and so that's why I have sent
letters to the ambassadors of four
countries Mexico El Salvador Guatemala
and Honduras asking them to please do
everything they can to inform people in
their country that this is not true that
our law does not allow them to come here
and stay and that they're endangering
their children's lives and um so this
this issue is reminiscent of other Mass
migration issues we've faced in the past
we've had mass migrations from Cuba from
the Dominican Republic and other places
and this one is endemic of that
unfortunate this one is an example of
that uh the the the further challenge
that we have is that our infrastructure
is not built to address this the border
patrol is designed to patol the border
and prevent illegal Crossings of people
weapons and drugs they're not there to
provide care and I think we're asking
for a humanitarian crisis here we're
continuing to house young Miners and
Facilities that weren't Des designed to
House people so this is a very serious
issue that needs to be confronted I
think the first step is to get the ward
out in those countries that you can't
stay and then ultimately do what we can
to process those kids through that
system and and return them to to a safer
environment one
last thank you Senator
um last year uh John MC Senator John
McCain referring to uh immigrants said
they uh mow our Lawns and care for our
children um I believe this is offensive
to immigrants as well as Americans but I
think he's echoing the sentiment of
Democrats
and the US Chamber of Commerce when he
says things like that when I was younger
um and I'm probably about your age I I
was a porter um I did painting Roofing
siding um I even dug ditches for uh for
septic fields so I completely reject
that notion um my question to you
regarding immigration as it relates to
our economy is how can we justify more
and more low skilled labor when we have
uh you know we have 50 million people on
food stamps we have uh 99 weeks of
unemployment um lowest labor
participation rate since the Carter
Administration so it would seem to me
that more people of all backgrounds more
Americans of all backgrounds would
perform work like I did or even pick the
lettuce if the government would stop
paying them to not all of them but a
large majority of them for uh basically
uh you know being nonproductive so I
guess the question really is what's the
best policy um you know to address both
immigration and the uh well first of all
you do have industries that rely
predominantly on migrant labor in
particular in the agricultural industry
as you've outline as a function of
global competition uh because low labor
costs abroad make it difficult for for
our agriculture industry to compete if
it has to pay uh Beyond a certain
threshold although by the way labor
costs in our agriculture industry are
also uh regulated at a certain minimum
level but I think what you're getting at
is a second question and that is is our
immigration system a 24st century
immigration system and the answer is it
is not our current immigration system is
primarily a family reunification system
it is a system that is built to re reun
reunify families so if you have an
Innovative new product or idea or have
some special skill or Merit that perhaps
you could contribute to the economy your
chances of getting into the US are often
no better than someone who simply has a
mother or father living here and that is
a system that potentially made sense in
the earlier to Mid part of the 20th
century in fact full frankness that's
how my parents came because her sister
was living in the United States it does
not reflect the 21st century the 21st
century immigration system has to be
primarily a merit-based immigration
system one in which immigrants to the US
come primarily on the basis of what they
can contribute to the economy uh and and
and I've just described to you that we
have an economy where in order to
succeed you have to have a higher level
of skill and educational attainment and
our and our immigration system needs to
reflect that that alone is a reason why
the immigration law needs to be reformed
beyond that you need to be able to
enforce your immigration laws your
immigration laws are only as good as
your ability to enforce them every
nation on the planet enforces their
immigration law Mexico enforces their
immigration laws uh you know Canada
enforces their immigration laws we need
to enforce our immigration laws our
existing mechanism for enforcing
immigration laws don't work well we have
three sectors of the border that remain
largely insecured about 80% of these
children are crossing in one of those
sectors in the real ground area we know
what works because the other six sectors
have been largely secured due to
investment and both Personnel technology
and structures we have to have 40% of
our illegal immigrants in this country
entered legally they came on an airplane
and they stayed and we have no way of
tracking that because we're like a hotel
that checks you in but never checks you
out and uh and we have no ment mechanism
for employers to ver that are that
employers are required to use in
verifying that who they're hiring is
legally here um right now you can show
up with a paper document and say this is
me and this is my Social Security card
and quite frankly the employer hasn't
have to go much further than that other
than a goodfaith effort we need to have
an electronic based system that
employers are required to use to verify
that who they're hiring is who they say
they are and that they're legally here
because that's the magnet that's
attracting much of this illegal
immigration the last challenge we face
is the hardest one politically and that
is what do you do with 12 million human
beings that are living in the United
States illegally I can tell you what
we're not going to do we're not going to
award 12 million people citizenship and
we're not going to round up and Deport
12 million people my the fundamental
challenge we face in Washington today is
we will never have the votes or the
political space or any chance at all of
having the votes to address that issue
of what to do with those 12 million
until you've done the other two things
first until people believe that truly
the borders have been secured the Visa
overstays are being being controlled and
stopped and there's an employee
verification system people are not
willing to have a conversation about
what to do with those that are here
illegally people may not like it but
that's the way it is that is a fact that
is not a matter of opinion that is a
fact it is something I have said now for
the better part of a year until we
address those other things I think
people are willing to have a responsible
conversation about what to do with the
existing problem but not until they know
for sure that this isn't going to happen
again and uh and and I think an approach
that says trust us isn't going to Li and
and that that is uh that's where we
stand today on the whole issue thank you
so much I appreciate
it